FEMALE SPEAKER: This
is the director.
He also co-wrote, co-edited,
and co-produced the movie,
and it's Carlos Marques-Marcet.
CARLOS MARQUES
MARCET: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: He wanted to
share with you a funny story
about shooting Google
and the bizarre fact
that he's actually here.
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
Well, it's
actually a very long story.
It's very weird to be in this
building, because, as you saw,
that's a photograph of
this building in the movie,
of the [INAUDIBLE].
The funny thing is
when we were doing
the script of the movie,
my photographer friend, who
inspired the movie,
actually, he's a man,
but I changed the gender--
he came to visit me.
Then we decided, he read
the script and said,
oh, this photographer
doesn't work like that.
I'll come through Los
Angeles, we'll make a project,
we've got a grant from an
art institution and UCLA
to help us and everything.
We'll give you support so
you can make this art project
before making the movie.
So you have on one side the art
project, and on the other side
you have the movie, and
we'll use the art project
to use it in the movie.
The funny thing
is like, OK, so we
started working on one thing.
We shot on the
antennas, and then
the antennas gave us
the idea, and then
we shot the Google
building, but we
didn't know it was Google at
the time, because like I said,
when we took the picture,
it wasn't bought.
And then the news came
on-- Google has bought,
and it's like oh, somehow
it gave us the key to all.
Maybe that's what the
photographic project needs
to be, just randomly,
because it got bought.
Then he's like, OK, we said
the thing about all the tools,
you see the physicality
of internet.
We all wonder, OK, internet,
but where is internet?
Filmmakers, we shoot
things, we shoot things
that you can touch, that you
can see, you don't shoot ideas.
So it was like, how do
you shoot the internet?
Where is it?
I want to see it.
That wasn't where-- we were
trying to find this service
and everything.
But also Google
Maps, we're obsessed
with Google Maps and this
thing that you can use
to travel all around the world.
It reminds me a lot of the
Lumiere brothers with the two
screens.
The Lumiere brothers were the
first one doing films-- well,
in America it was Edison,
but for the rest of the world
it was the Lumieres.
I love it.
Basically, they do
panoramics of the world
all around just to show
people how was Istanbul,
how was this country they've
never seen before in France.
It's like, woah.
I feel nowadays Google
Maps makes the same thing.
You just Google a
street view and you
could have the same panoramic
view of anywhere in the world.
Anyway, we were obsessed,
and it's like, OK,
we have to photograph
the tools, and also,
let's photograph the Google car.
Then it was like, impossible.
We got the [INAUDIBLE]
and everything,
but how do you reach Google?
It's seems very funny, but we
try any way, all the emails,
all the contacts possible
through the university,
through something else.
There was no way.
We even came to-- not
these offices, because they
were still in the other
offices in Santa Monica--
we went there to the door.
I'm trying to ask somebody,
knock on the [INAUDIBLE].
Can we get in?
We're not bad people,
we're not crazy people,
we just want to
talk with Google.
It was impossible
to talk with Google.
And then we decided, OK, you
cannot to talk with Google,
Google talks with you.
That was actually what happened,
and now I'm in the building.
But in a funny way, we decided,
OK, let's go to Silicon Valley,
let's go to Google city.
There's a place where Google is.
We just went there, and we
looked for the Google car,
and we found it in some corner.
Then we just took the tripod,
took the picture, and went.
Then it was funny,
because it was so hard,
but then when we
asked for permission,
Google said, yeah,
fine, use the picture.
Everything's fine.
It's the weird structure
of the internet.
There's no centers, you
really can't reach any center
at any point.
It was very like
being in the castle,
you know, a little
bit Kafka-ian.
It's funny, because that's
how all the artistic projects
started, because then we
were in Silicon Valley.
For them it's like
the most strange place
in the world, like very weird,
like all these buildings there.
Then we start taking
all the pictures,
and that's where all the
email at the end, she says,
all the ideas came from.
The funny thing,
we went to Yahoo
and we did the same thing,
we just took the tripod,
went to this basket court
field-- court field, you say?
Yeah, I think-- with the
camera, took the picture,
and left, with no
permission or anything.
Then we say, OK
that's in the movie,
so let's ask for permission.
Then they said, oh, it's fine,
but this is the old logo.
Maybe you're can Photoshop
it and put the new logo.
So that's basically what we did.
It was an experience to deal
with all of the new technology
companies.
They have a different mentality
that still I don't understand,
but it was kind of Kafka-ian.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Carlos, I
did some research on you,
and I had a quote from you about
a movie that you really loved,
an Italian movie from 1963.
I'm sorry, you'll have
to actually pronounce it.
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
I fidanzati.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right,
and the director?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
Ermanno Olmi.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It was a
remarkable first scene.
I think in the
first three minutes
there's one word
spoken, and yet, you're
already captured and
intrigued with what happens.
Why?
Why did she do that?
I wanted to ask you, you start
this movie with a couple making
love, right?
It's really right there.
It's not vulgar.
It's very tasteful, natural,
but it starts the movie
and it ends the movie.
Why did you choose to do that?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
Well, to me
there's something
about sexuality
that is the most intimate
language that couples have.
Somehow it was a way to show
this evolution, this change.
Sometimes I get a
little bit annoyed
when you see movies that
just try to show you
sex to get you horny.
Sometimes it's fine.
Sometimes you are in the mood
and that's great, actually.
FEMALE SPEAKER: But that
wasn't why you did it.
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
That wasn't why I did it
and sometimes it's just-- I
like when it has a meaning, when
it's doing something.
To me, it would be doing a
dialogue between two people,
just not with words,
but with bodies.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I know that
your background initially-- I
know you studied filmmaking--
but you started as an editor.
I was just wondering,
when I started in TV news,
I started as an editor.
I remember being on the field
and really feeling my stories.
I would hear the sound bite,
oh, my story's going to start.
That's the sound.
Do you feel that your way
of even writing the movie
has been affected by the
fact that you were initially
an editor?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
Yeah, and I
think the whole
concept of the movie
was already very editing-based.
The length of the
shot, just calculating
how long the scenes
were going to be,
short scenes with long scenes.
The pacing was already very
present on the writing, I feel.
Even when this
[INAUDIBLE] long take,
but it's already written
as an editing long take.
I wasn't really
planning already-- it's
hard to say, to explain, but
you basically think on shots
and how to transition
to one to another
in a way that you
will do an editing,
but just without cutting.
That has to be in
the writing, too,
in the way to go from
some place to another,
and how this time happens in
one side, or in which pace,
and which action.
I think basically
editing is like music,
it's like playing music.
There was something of it
that was already present
in the script.
I'm terrible, I have no ears,
so I'm horrible with music,
so it's kind of my way of trying
to get something with that.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Was this the movie
you thought you
were going to make?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET: Sorry?
FEMALE SPEAKER: When you
had the finished product,
was that the movie you thought
you were going to make?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET: To me,
for many directors, that's
their goal.
They have a movie
in their mind, they
want to see it on the
screen, and yes, I'm
happy because it looks
like what I imagined.
For me it happens a little bit
the opposite when I'm shooting.
If I shoot a scene that
is exactly as I expected,
as I imagined,
something is wrong.
I know I like to go to
shoot and get something
that I didn't expect.
I shoot a lot of takes
sometimes, just waiting
that something new happens
that is not on the screen
but is better, some
sort the reality bridge
or something that surprises you.
I will say yes, it's very
similar in some ways,
but the parts that
I like the most
are the parts that
are not as similar.
For example, one of my
favorite moments of the movie
is the moment where,
in the last scene,
when they are you
drinking whisky,
there's this long silence,
and the dog starts barking.
That's probably one of my
favorite moments of the movie.
Of course, this dog
started barking by itself.
I told the actors, just
wait until the dog stops,
and then you can start talking.
Then it never
stopped, so then it
became this action
moment that was
exactly what the scene needed.
It's like, oh, thanks,
there's something.
I couldn't give that direction.
That wouldn't have
existed in my mind,
and that's what I'm
always searching for.
It's almost like a rush of
something unexpected happening.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Did the actors
bring something to the movie
that you hadn't expected?
Perhaps something you liked?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
Yeah, a lot.
Of course, the sense
of humor of it.
It always was thought of as a
drama, but then shooting it,
we had so much fun working.
We were laughing so much.
Then suddenly, the movie
got much more light
than it was originally intended.
I feel like the
audiences laugh a lot.
I was surprised, even, because
it wasn't planned like this,
but it's just what it came with.
Natalia's energy, the
character was more
like a quiet character,
and she still
is, but Natalia the actress,
she's like a tornado.
Not like the character at all.
I think she brings this,
somehow, in little doses
to her character.
I think they change
the character.
Originally, she was not British.
It's when we cast
her that we decided,
oh, actually, if she's
British, it will work better.
I always work with whatever
I have on my hands.
It's not like--
you've got a script,
say it's an
exterior, day, sunny.
Then you go, oh, it's
raining, we don't shoot.
For me, is more like,
oh it's raining.
What happens if it's raining?
Let's try to figure it out.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You shot it
on a Red EPIC camera, right?
So was that hard to shoot
with low lighting resolution?
Did you have to light
it in a particular way?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET: Yeah, it
was kind of an issue sometimes.
Like Alex is now, or they
got better low-light.
But at the same time,
I like to use the EPIC
because it has the 4K.
We planned a little
bit of re-framing.
Not doing it imposed,
but already shooting it,
we were planning them.
That's why we decided
to shoot with the EPIC.
The problem is that, for
example, for this first scene,
we shot with the
lights-- you don't have
anywhere to hide the lights.
You just basically
have to use windows.
Dagmar, the DP, is she's
an amazing director
of photography, and we
basically always think
of lighting spaces.
That's how we function.
We light the space and
I make the blocking
with the actors,
thinking already,
what's the possibilities
of the space?
Basically, I use
the props, because I
don't like to use marks.
I don't like the act of
saying, you have to step.
They can do it,
but to me, I just
want to be totally free
to be able to create.
So I put, here is
the coffee pot,
so I know he needs to his mark.
The props are their marks.
Then we work with knowing
where the props are
and where we're going
to put the lights.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do you like
Red cameras in particular?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
Yeah, I enjoy them a lot.
Like a lot of the [INAUDIBLE]
before like [INAUDIBLE],
I like them a lot,
too, but there's
something about the Red, it
has its own specific colors
and everything.
I've really enjoyed
having the 4K.
Some days it can
be very dangerous,
if you just use-- because
in cinema you have 4K now,
so normally you end
up screening 2K.
Basically, you can
do re-framings,
and move the camera.
You can become a lazy filmmaker.
But if you plan it well, and
if you think of it in a way
that this is part
of your language,
not as something you do as a
way of trying to solve problems,
as a way of a
creative tool, I think
it has a lot of possibilities.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I hear
the Red's fairly heavy.
Did you use it like-- is it a
gyro stabilizer for the walking
shot or the movement shots?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET: It's
all in tripod, some tripod
and with all machine.
It's all very big.
Some people use Steadicams as
a way to substitute a dolly,
but it's not the same.
There's actually
very few filmmakers
who know how to use Steadicam.
A lot of times it's
an easy tool to use,
but to me the problem was,
because it makes your life much
easier, for us it would
have been much easier
to go with a Steadicam
here and there.
But the problem
with the Steadicams
is that they are
called Steadicams,
but they never stay steady.
They always have
these things that
are floating and everything.
For us it was important to
stay at the moment with them,
so we used these old
machines like in the 1940s
with the smaller cameras.
It's beautiful.
There's something-- you
see like Douglas they may
be starting even huge cameras.
Now they are small.
You can feel the weight of the
[GROAN], Gone with the Wind,
and then it's like, woah.
There's something about
that is very beautiful,
I feel, of being on the ground.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I also read
that you said that you don't
choose a movie, it chooses you.
So I feel like sometimes,
when you're in a relationship,
there's a moment
where you're like,
that was when I fell
in love with him.
Was there a moment when
this movie chose you?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
That's a good question.
There's a first moment
where it makes it click .
That normally
happened when I have
ideas for movies and with
shows before, and everything.
I have this idea floating,
this other idea floating,
and then suddenly it
just makes that click.
In that case, it was
oh, there's internet.
I wanted to explore
all the language
of long-distance relationships,
the language of webcams
and screens.
Then my friend [INAUDIBLE] the
photographer, came to visit me,
and then he told me
click, click, click.
Oh, yes, a photographer
coming to Los Angeles,
and then it's like,
boom, they are born.
There's a spark
that goes in there,
and then it's like,
OK, that's an idea.
It that grabs you and
it doesn't leave you.
I think it's almost
like first sight love.
It's mostly that afterwards
you cannot hate it.
In a relationship, you
fall in love at the moment,
and then you're
seven years together,
and then there's
no sex or anything.
Then you have to fall in
love again, and go to dinner,
and then you can fall in love.
It's mostly like pre-falling
in love again and again.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You said that
the last scene was emotionally
challenging for you.
I wanted to know why.
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
I guess, of course,
there's a personal
part on the story,
but I haven't lived exactly.
I've never gone
to a door, nobody
has ever come to my door.
But there was something
about this material
of just showing the breakup.
Somehow, when they ask me if
this movie is autobiographical,
it is, and it is not,
in many ways, but maybe
it sums up all my
failed relationships.
Somehow, it was trying to
confront what happens when you
still love somebody but you
know that you cannot live a life
together, and trying to really
go deep into this moment
and not planning.
I was very concerned
about going into the scene
with very pre-formed ideas.
I wanted to be vulnerable,
me as the director,
too, not really knowing
what needs to be.
I know what they want to
capture, but I don't know how.
It was very funny, actually, in
the rehearsals with the actors,
they always explain the
story, because I normally
record the rehearsals, but this
time I just left them alone.
They were having
sex and they'd turn,
it's like, where
is the director?
But then when
you're sad, you have
to be-- I think it
was Herzog who said,
a director can never cry
on set, and it's true.
You have to be very cold-minded
and be able to analyze,
just guide the
actors and tell them,
this is not working
here or there.
This is happening, you have
to be almost scientific there
while also
corresponding and being
sympathetic to their feelings,
but being able to analyze them.
I was very afraid to have to do
both things at the same time,
being able to have
both your right
and left sides of
the brain connected
and the same then confront
them in a way that
is the ending of your movie.
Actually we didn't shoot
it until-- the night
before, I was watching movies,
like sex scenes and everything,
maybe they have a solution, but
of course, it was all stupid.
But then, I didn't shoot it
until the last shot, almost.
I guess I was looking for this
magic to happen where, oh yeah,
it's cut.
It's right in the moment
when the sun is coming out,
the [INAUDIBLE] is
going to get married,
the taxi's on the floor,
she's missing her plane.
These dramatic moments
of them happened.
It gives you a rush.
At the end, I feel
like if we make them,
we make movies for the
pleasure of making them
into these little flash moments.
I guess it was a way
of pushing myself
into this limited situation.
Of course, I'm not doing
like "Fitzcarraldo."
I'm not sending a
boat over a mountain,
but still, you're
looking for this moment
where something magical,
some kind of truth happens,
or you feel that
happens for yourself.
FEMALE SPEAKER: If that was
the most challenging part
of the movie, emotionally,
what was probably
the most fun or most awesome
moment for you in the movie?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET: There
was a lot of fun moments.
From the moment where they
are trying to throw things
at one another, and
then when it happened,
we tried so many times.
Every time was fun.
I do a lot the takes so
we tried to make it funny.
Then when it happened, we all
look at each other, like, woah,
it looked like it went through.
The first scene
was a lot of fun,
because it's like
a choreography.
It gives you also
a rush because it's
like, OK, you're getting closer
to the time, but you know,
it still is like 20 minutes.
Everything needs to be perfect,
and when it happens, go crazy,
and we shout.
It seems like it was
the end of the world,
hugging everybody, oh, sad.
It was something special.
It was fun to shoot.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
want to read you
a quote I read that you wrote.
I hope you don't mind.
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET: No,
you're very well-prepared.
You're probably the
best-prepared interview
I've had.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You wrote, "It's
a problem with our generation:
it's difficult to
plan for the future,
not just because of
the financial crisis,
but also because
of hedonism, which
is the antithesis of sacrifice.
And this whole debate on what
self-sacrifice means is also
very interesting."
I think I quote you
from March, 2014.
I wanted to ask you,
in that statement,
are you talking
about our generation
being more self-orientated and
losing a sense of community?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
Yeah, I wouldn't
want to fall into cliches
of yeah, just [INAUDIBLE]
and everything.
I feel somehow it's a
liberation, also, in many ways,
of some rules that we narrate.
The weight of tradition has
been the rule of society,
like most of societies until
now that sentence so fast.
I feel you have a family,
have to have kids,
the woman is at home,
the husband goes to work.
If you're high-class,
nobody works,
you just live off of
the money of the others.
So it's great.
But it was very clear,
and then suddenly, there's
this discourse of
authenticity that in some ways
is very nice,
because you just try
to find whatever
makes you happy,
and there's no way, no rule.
But that makes it also
very hard to-- there's
a discourse of finding
yourself that also sometimes
can be very distracting from
the things that you really need.
It's a contradiction
sometimes, because trying
to find yourself,
you're not yourself
if it's not compared
to other people,
in a framing of other people.
We sometimes forget that
this philosopher who
wrote a whole book about it,
basically talking-- we all
need to be special nowadays, no?
And you can be the guy who has
like 14,322 hairs on your head.
But what does that mean?
Does it mean anything
for somebody else?
I feel there's something in
this idea of-- in building
relationships, a lot
of things sometimes
happen and the thing
is just like, oh yeah,
professional life
against-- I wanted
to be made aware of that, of
professional schools, family,
and [INAUDIBLE].
It's more like, there's
no one route now,
so now it's really hard to
find somebody who you can
partner for a long, long time.
That's a choice,
not an obligation.
I think the sacrifice
thing-- it's funny,
I had to cut a bunch of
the dialogue of the movie
because I think it
was too explicit,
but there was a moment
in the ending scene
where he was telling her, we
don't know how to sacrifice.
We're a generation
where we don't know.
Then she said, oh, my
parents did sacrifice,
and it didn't work out
very well for them.
So that true.
There's both sides of sacrifice.
It shouldn't feel--
sacrifice if not-- it's
a dangerous line in
that relationship.
You have to put effort,
and what this effort
means, because then we
start to basically go
to think in the relationship,
oh, is it worth it?
Should I invest so much
effort in this relationship?
The outcome is not-- so we start
to enter with the mentality
that it's not about an outcome,
it's love, you give it,
and maybe you return, maybe not.
I think it's dangerous to
get into those channels,
and sacrifice is something
you do expecting nothing.
But at the same time, there's
a connotation that [INAUDIBLE].
Catholic kind of
connotation is horrible.
As a Catholic, I say it.
I'm not practicing, but,
[INAUDIBLE] Catholic, I guess.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do you
have a dream project
that you would love
to make one day?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
A dream project?
Wow.
It's very hard to say,
because to me, things
go very one to another.
If they had asked
me 10 years ago,
I would never have
said I had done
the movie like the one I did.
Just supposing that I'm
going to be something
that I am now in
10 years, and that
would be most
horrible thing if I'm
the same person in 10 years.
It's really hard to think.
I guess doing
something meaningful,
but there's always
ideas and projects,
but something that I
like at some moment,
then you don't have it anymore.
This is very hard because
ideas change for me.
I would love my project
will be making movies
until I'm 105 years old,
like Manoel de Oliveira.
I like his movies, I'm not a
super fan, but if they ask me,
which filmmaker
would you like to be?
It's him.
105 and making movies,
what else do you want?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do you
have a purpose in life,
and do you think you're
going to fulfill that purpose
unless you're making a movie?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
I know I'm going to die.
[LAUGHTER]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Is there a
story you really want to tell?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
I guess I don't
want to think too
much, because then you
start to get, oh,
yeah, I'm an author,
or, that's my discourse
about the world,
and I should be talking
about these things.
I prefer just to think about
the things that really worry me,
and what are the things
that really move me now,
and be with my
instinct at the moment.
Because if not, I can
get very egocentric.
Your ego-- your ego is
just a part of yourself.
You have many more other
parts, much more interesting.
Right now I'm interested in
investigating the relationships
of how we're changing nowadays.
There's this French
saying, [INAUDIBLE],
the real is painted as you
see it, being of your time.
That, to me, was right
now, it's important
trying to investigate
what's happening around me.
Making films, to me,
is a way to really
be able to-- the
luxury to investigate
and also re-create how you feel.
It's a luxurious job.
I'm still weird when
I say, oh are you
going to pay me to do this job?
Really?
It's great, but sometimes it
feels like a blessing more
than a job.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Does anybody
have a question for Carlos?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
in the movie
they have a long-distance
relationship, but in general,
do you think that
technology actually
helps people get closer, or
are they doing the opposite?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
No, it's a good question.
I don't have answer for it.
Somehow the movie offers
more questions than answers.
That's true.
I think technology is like
anything, how you use it.
It's like, atomic
energy, is it good?
Depends.
I think the same thing,
it can bring you closer,
but at the same time, it
can bring you farther away,
because of the feeling
that you are close,
but you live without being
aware of the things that you're
missing.
You think that just having a
computer, you know somebody,
that you can talk
everyday, and pretend
that you could have just
a normal, everyday life
with somebody that is so far.
That can harm a lot
of relationships,
because at the end,
physicality and presence
is such an important
part of a relationship.
At the same time,
it can keep you
in contact with many people.
I always say the same,
but I talk more sometimes
with my parents when I'm
abroad then when I'm home.
When I'm home, you go
to dinner on Sundays,
it a bunch of family people,
and you don't say anything.
Then when you're in
front of a computer,
then you have to talk.
Then, woah, you talk about
many things I never expected.
I will have talks with them.
It all depends on the situation.
What is important is to see
what we lose and what we win,
and try to use them
the best way possible.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First, I wanted to thank you
for coming here and making
this film.
I've gone through a long
distance relationship myself,
so some of the stuff is
very resonate with me.
I just want to say
that I really like
the song you chose,
the Magnetic Fields
song "Nothing Matters When
We're Dancing" for the movie.
I thought it was used very
well knitting the two scenes.
How did you choose that song?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
It's probably
one of the very few
things that's still there
from the very first
draft of the movie.
It actually was
there all the time.
At the time, coming
through Los Angeles,
that's when I
started writing this,
almost like seven years ago.
I was very much rediscovering
The Magnetic Fields,
and listening again,
the song was like, wow,
there's something
about-- Stephin Merritt
has this ability to write
these lyrics in a way that
is almost cheesy, but it's not.
It feels the feelings,
but with a certain irony
that is not sarcastic.
That was the tone for me.
I wanted to use some irony, but
I didn't want a distant irony.
I wanted to be close
to the characters
be able to explore feelings.
Of course, there was also
a part of the lyrics that
has to do with
dancing, and dancing
is something you
can only do when
you are in front of each other.
Then, through the song,
the idea of the scene
came on, of them dancing
with the computers.
So it's OK, nothing
happens when we're dancing,
but what happens when
we are not dancing?
That was a little
bit of the idea,
almost, that I started
the movie with.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
bringing us the movie.
CARLOS MARQUES
MARCET: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: It's a beautiful film.
I wanted to talk to
you about the editing.
You have a lot of long
takes at the beginning,
and I love editing.
At one point Robert Wise
said that, as an editor, when
he became a director, he
found that he was shooting
more coverage, not less.
At the beginning of the
film and throughout the film
you have some really
long takes, which
also seem to parallel
the video conference,
because you really don't
have another take when you're
video conferencing with people.
How much of that
thought came in for you
about what were shooting?
Did you feel as an editor
that you wanted more coverage?
Did you intentionally
go for the longer takes?
Did the Red camera
help that because you
didn't have an end
of a reel coming
and I'm running out of film?
How did that affect you, and
what was your plan with these?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
I didn't know
that he-- that's a quote from
Robert Wise, that he shot more?
He shot more coverage?
AUDIENCE: He said that to
me, I ask him a while ago.
That is what he said,
is that he always felt--
CARLOS MARQUES
MARCET: You met him?
AUDIENCE: I worked for him.
He said--
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET: Now I
want to ask you a question.
AUDIENCE: I was trying
not to go there.
It's just, I love him too.
I mean, brilliant editor.
But I always felt that,
that's why I asked him.
I would think as a
director your mind would
be so focused on what you were
going to create that I'd think
he knew exactly what he wanted.
He said no, he just
made them shoot more.
And you're an editor-- started
out as an editing and filming.
Especially now that you have
the digital tools that he never
had, I would love to know what
your thoughts are on that.
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
It's funny,
I have a lot of of friends
who go into directing.
Most of them shoot
very little coverage.
I think they are more
precise on the way
that they are going to use it.
It's hardly that
they shoot-- I think
as an editor you tend to shoot
things that you-- you do more
takes until you
get the right take,
and then you don't shoot
things you're not going to use.
Sometimes, in coverage,
there's this idea of,
let's do things just in case.
Let's do all these
long master and then
they discovered this angle,
and cover this angle,
and cover this angle, and
then I'll decide on the post.
I feel as an editor, you already
have anything in your mind,
pretty much.
When something new happens,
you're already thinking, OK,
that new thing happened but now
I need shoot this thing here.
So you're already taking
pieces as they happen, as you
get surprised, too, sometimes.
I think it also makes you want
to-- for example, something
that influenced
me, I feel like I
wouldn't have done this very
long take at the beginning
if it wasn't in the beginning.
As an editor you
know that a very long
take in the middle of
the movie, it's probably
going to go to the
bin, because you
have to be a master of having
the rhythm of the whole movie
on your mind in a way that
it's almost impossible.
In the middle, you've
created, and then finally you
end up breaking it up.
But at the beginning,
you're setting up
the tone of your movie.
You can see as it's developing
what's going to be the theme.
You don't need to compare it to
what's come before and after.
I think that's another
difference, probably,
or something that
makes you think a lot,
is that you are very aware of
what's come before and after.
I guess all directors, but
especially which as an editor,
know how you make a
transition from this scene
to the other scene, or on
the way of shooting it.
To me, at least, an
experience with my friends
is that they shoot less,
but they shoot more takes.
AUDIENCE: As I said, did
you plan longer takes also
because of parallels
video conferencing that
was going to happen later?
Because it feels the same.
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
There was a little game--
I'm thinking of a
game of piloting
the camera and the other
camera, and I always
fantasize the idea of what
cameras are going to be, like,
4K quality in a few years.
And there's got to be
a nice rhyme in there.
To me, it was important
just to be with them.
We discussed a lot
with the co-writer,
this is somehow a movie
between the difference
of being thrown off somebody,
in the image of somebody,
also the difference of a two
shot and a shot reverse shot.
I shot reverse
shot, then it feels
like they are in front of them,
but it's like an abstraction.
And somehow, being in front of
a computer is an abstraction.
We wanted to follow them so
you have any [INAUDIBLE],
you don't have
any buildup thing,
and you're just with
them, sitting with them
and you share with
them this reality.
It was not very metaphoric.
I don't like too many metaphors,
but more giving a feeling.
Probably the reason
for this long thing,
it was not as much
the thing itself,
but the moment of the cut.
The moment you cut, I knew that
was going to have an effect.
You're going to miss for
the rest of the movie
this moment where they've
been together in space.
So that was a little bit
between-- but it was also
like the beginning,
the second take,
when you see him
showing the apartment,
obviously that was the idea of
reminding of the first scene,
but somehow then there
is a cut, and then
you see him in the other room.
There's an abstraction in there.
AUDIENCE: I really
appreciated your editing
and the way it was shot.
Thanks.
CARLOS MARQUES MARCET: I'll ask
you questions about Robert Wise
after.
I'm very impressed.
So
AUDIENCE: One of the
things, of course,
that was in this, a lot
was moving to the computer
technology with the lower
resolution and other things
with lag and
pixelation and freezes.
Now, did you use
those all natural,
or where there
certain places where
you felt you kind of
needed special effects to a
get the feeling you
wanted from that?
CARLOS MARQUES-MARCET:
It's funny,
because I was very concerned.
I really wanted to get
this texture of the pixel,
and I feel there's some beauty
to it, especially [INAUDIBLE]
converting with the
[INAUDIBLE] that came around
and then you had those
conversions of movies.
You have all these masses of
pixels moving from one side
to another.
It was almost like
a experimental film
and I have safe movies
converted of this beauty.
To me, all video chats have
kind of the same feeling,
which, at the show
two years before,
the technology in two years
got so much better, like a year
before.
So we didn't have as
many pixels as we wanted.
Actually some scenes--
obviously there
were scenes where we were
cutting, and breaking up.
Then it was painful because
we had to shoot again.
The actress was like,
ahhh, getting crazy.
Of course, the
moment, the day we
had to shoot the scene
where the connection breaks
the [INAUDIBLE] and
everything, that day,
the connection was
completely perfect.
There was no way
could make it worse.
OK, let's try it
with a cellphone.
3G.
Still perfect.
We had to move everything out.
So I had to do something.
I had to do some of the stuff,
like, basically freezing, just
with the freezing, but
very simple things.
I even do it with
the [INAUDIBLE].
I didn't have to do any kind
of after-effects or anything.
The good thing with shooting
this with video chats,
we recorded the screen, so
you're actually always shooting
three cameras somehow.
The thing is that you can make
several takes into one, even
if you've done 20 takes,
you can make a freeze frame,
and then cut, and then
put another frame.
So there's a lot of editing
hidden in these jump cuts,
but they're not jump cuts.
That's my little trick there.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you so
much, it was a wonderful time.
CARLOS MARQUES
MARCET: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]